the tension runs Deep In Black Panther
wakanda forever and fans are taking
sides about one of the most intense
scenes in the movie that feature two
beloved characters warning spoilers
ahead interactor Ryan coogler's epic
return to the world he first introduced
to us in 2018 black panther wakanda
forever is filled with heated encounters
and intense confrontations what comes as
a true shock is that some of the most
jaw-dropping moments are between
wakanda's own people with the nation
still raw from the loss of their great
king t'challa emotions run High
especially between those that were
closest to him none feel more intense
however than the serving Okoye endures
from Queen ramonda who might deliver one
of the most soul-shattering moments the
MCU has ever seen following her defeat
at the hands of Neymar's dedicated
Warrior atuma Okoye is forced to return
home to break the news that from her
understanding sure he has been taken by
Neymar's soldiers and her status as Dead
or Alive is unknown the information
sends a queen into a of Rage ending with
a stripping okay of her title as general
of the Dora melange and expelling her
from service
it's an electrifying moment that shows
both actors at the top of their game as
Angela Bassett says through her co-star
while the Nigeria's devoted Soldier is
forced to take the hit thanks to these
Sterling performances fans have mixed
emotions about who was in the right
since the film's release bassettes in
particular has received plenty of praise
for what is likely her final appearance
as Queen ramonda in wakanda forever I'm
ready at fans are quick to chime in on
the scene noting that Guerrera sold the
scene as much as Bassett did Juan poster
said Angela Bassett killed it as ramonda
a scene where she yells at Okoye felt so
raw while another added deny Guerrera
was amazing in that scene too they both
killed it I felt like both characters
were right and were making great points
the greatest complexities came from the
characters opposing views in the first
black panther film which was something
that Queen mamonda didn't forget
is not coming
that they still with killmonger and the
throne following t'challa's defeat and
that trust was still a fragile thing
which Okoye officially broken a failure
to protect shuri I read its user said it
was so well balanced Okoye both deserved
to be fired and not I didn't know what
to think and yes they both acted
amazingly fueled by Passion from both
sides of an argument fans were Keen to
break down just who was in the wrong
about what to do following shuri's
disappearance one user got fully caught
up in the moment saying when the queen
reminded her Okoye that she's still with
killmonger I was like oh damn that's
right she did do that of course by
bringing back seemingly unresolved
issues it sparked at a debate over
whether okoye's Devotion to the throne
was something that should have been
acknowledged another user defended the
toughest member of the Dora milaje
saying killmonger won the throne
according to their Traditions so it's
not like he really did it wrong another
writer started one of my favorite scenes
in Black Panther was that discussion of
Duty versus personal feelings it was a
very gray situation whichever side you
stand on there's no denying the
highlight of basset's performance which
some say should get attention come
Awards season a user posted she should
be nominated for best supporting actress
literally felt like I was watching
royalty but let's face it vassette is
Hollywood royalty could be the first
acting nomination for an MCU film too
given that the first black panther got
so much Awards attention in 2018 basa
getting a nod from the academy could be
on the horizon
foreign
[Music]